[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue pour la dernière émission de la
semaine qui sera aussi la plus
passionnante c'est le principe du
bouquet final nous allons parler
aujourd'hui de quatre sujets d'actualité
la nomination attendue puisqu'il est
seul candidat de christophe castaner
comme déléguée générale de la république
en marche peut-il rester au gouvernement
doit-il faire un choix nous en
discuterons nous parlerons de jean luc
mélenchon qui fait l'objet de deux
enquêtes journalistiques de nos confrère
l'express est capital le cannois maire
devra encore tenez contre moi c'est pas
moi qui le dit je voudrais pas c'est
jean luc mélenchon à juste titre on en
parlera nous reviendrons aussi sur les
prières de re qui avait lieu à clichy la
garenne
depuis plusieurs mois chaque vendredi
mais pas aujourd'hui puisque le préfet
des hauts-de-seine les a interdits et
puis on regardera tous ensemble c'est
incroyable vidéo de d'un robot humanoïde
absolument performant regardez il fait
des choses que même nous on n'arriverait
pas à faire et est-ce que c'est
dangereux est ce qu'il faut s'en réjouir
ou s'en inquiéter
nous en reparlerons avec nos quatre
invités
bonsoir hervé nathan bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes directeur
adjoint de la rédaction de marianne
marianne qui fait sa couverture cette
semaine sur
le harcèlement sexuel et les deux mille
victimes oubliées bonsoir jean lagrange
vous êtes président de dell sous
consulting et directeur général
denso agissent france bout de domaines
d'expertisé la communication numérique
l'e-réputation les stratégies
d'influencé bien ça bonsoir génie bastié
journaliste à la rubrique débats et
opinions du figaro vous êtes aussi
rédactrice en chef politique de la revue
limite votre dernier livre qu'ils
étaient peut-être premier aussi oui
voilà c'est que ce qui me semblait donc
votre dernier livre en date a dit aux
madmoizelles la défaite des femmes est
paru l'année dernière aux éditions du
cerf et carl meeus nous a rejoint
également bonsoir vous êtes le rédacteur
en chef politique du figaro magazine
figaro magazine qui met en couverture ce
week-end le les hommes du président et
en particulier deux personnages aussi
mystérieux que puissant le secrétaire
général de l'elysée et ses mails et mes
liens le conseiller spécial de macron et
vous avez participé associés notamment
pour voir comment quelle place
reste-t-il aux premiers ministres
edouard philippe
face à un exécutif élyséen aussi
omniprésent parlons donc pour commencer
restons plus exactement dans le parti du
président la république en marche vous
savez christophe castaner est le seul
candidat au poste de délégué général du
parti du président la dernière
discussion en date c'est de savoir
est-ce qu'il peut cumuler ce poste avec
celui de secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
et porte parole du gouvernement c'est sa
fonction actuelle est bien pour lui la
réponse est oui
avec un argument assez simple ben faut
bien vivre
je suis ni retraités
ni riches à tel point de pouvoir arrêter
toute activité et je prendrai un nouveau
métier je suis pas rémunéré sur ce
nouveau métier je suis juste un
animateur un facilitateur et à côté de
ça il faudrait que j'aie une activité
donc je cumulerait une activité on
attend que ce qu'on pensait de cet art
cet argumentaire il est bien tard
deviendrait députés dont une activité
saine de faire la loi le contrôle et le
gouvernement t auras dans ce poste là il
pourrait très bien être ce que le
président secrétaire général qu'est le
leader du parti la rider maternage le
délégué délégué général excusez moi je
cherche les termes voilà donc je ne
comprend pas une telle réponse hier que
ça veut dire que s'il est pas au
gouvernement et plus rien alors qu'il
est enrichi peut être député ça veut
dire quel mépris pour la représentation
nationale sous jacent voilà c'est ce que
je pense à autre chose et je sais qu'à
une polémique sur internet sert à moi ce
que je me souviens puisque je pense que
tu te souviens c'est que à part au parti
socialiste et au ps eu il ya encore une
dizaine ou une quinzaine d'années la
désignation par l'exécutif du leader du
parti
c'était une chose courante à droite
voilà et quand c'est au parti communiste
était dans un pays étranger pour
désigner le leader du parti
c'était le bon temps et ensuite on
réunissait un coup comme elle et la
république en marche on réunissait un
congrès pour faire applaudir donc une
certaine manière
voilà pardon jb c'est en fait bon la
vérité c'est probablement qu'il est
ministre il a envie de le rester
c'est humain non c'est quand même un
proche ce qui est ce qui gêne c'est le
décalage entre la volonté affichée des
macros de rompre avec la ligne politique
et cette pratique du cumul qui en effet
avait été utilisé par alain juppé
jacques chirac à nicolas sarkozy qui
était en même temps chef de la majorité
et au gouvernement
c'est pratique qui sont anciennes
tranche cette volonté de faire une
nouvelle politique et je pense que ça
montre également à quel point en marche
est en partie virtuelle qui n'a pas
réussi à faire émerger de nouveaux
talents et des seconds couteaux en fait
qui serait capable de rivaliser avec
castaner est le seul qu'on le seul
finalement dit non que dont dispose m
mais macron dans sa majorité avec
richard ferrand mais qui est un peu ça
ni par les affaires c'est 2k salaire il
n'y a pas de talent que réussi à émerger
de ce point de vue là on peut dire que
en marche n'a pas accompli ses promesses
comment il explique ça car mais j'avais
que l'engouement qui a eu autour de la
république en marche autour d' emmanuel
macron qui est entourée notamment à
l'elysée des plus brillants esprits de
la république on n'a pas réussi à
trouver un patron qui puisse cette halle
à plein temps pour le parti non parce
que tous ceux qui ont qui ont concouru à
la création d'un marchand fait son parti
à l'elysée
ismaël et mes liens qui est celui dont
on dit qu'il a vraiment tout organisé
dans les statuts tout ça je de normandie
je viens de normandie
tous les deux ont été à l'origine dans
marche ils ont créé ça et ils sont
aujourd'hui l'un à l'elysée et l'autre
au gouvernement et est au fond ce qui
est très curieux avec emmanuel macron à
la macro ni c'est qu'au fond il met à
des postes
je pense président du groupe à
l'international délégué général dans
marche des gens qui n'ont aucune envie
d'être là richard ferrand et richard
ferrand il voulait être ministre il a
fait tout ça c'est pas pour être
président du groupe d'ailleurs il ira
lille le fait suffisamment savoir
christophe castaner il n'était pas
candidat pour être délégué général il
était prévu était très content d'être au
gouvernement et il veut y rester
et bien pourtant c'est lui qui a été
nommé parce que en macro ni il ne faut
pas avoir ce que emmanuel macron appel
d'agenda caché il se méfie parce qu'il
faut dire qu'il a été à bonne école
d'expérience il a vu pendant cinq ans
manuel valls torpiller le quinquennat de
françois hollande parce qu'il avait son
agenda qui était je veux être moi
candidats que des cas une tête qui
dépasse il la sort du gouvernement
pourquoi je sais comment il la sort du
gouvernement mais en tout cas il ne la
nomme pas un poste où au lieu de de
faire de travailler pour emmanuel macron
il travaillerait pour lui je pense
exemple benjamin griveaux dont tout le
monde sait qu'il a des ambitions à paris
et qu'il était candidat pour être à la
tête en marche qui a été écarté parce
qu'à ce moment là s'il a été à la peine
dans marche il devrait plus penser qu'à
se faire élire à paris plutôt que
d'aider emmanuel macron là christophe
castaner comme il veut pas ça et qu'au
fond
alors il fera très bien le job est ce
qu'on découvre mais n'attend que
finalement emmanuel macron il n'est pas
aussi cool ce qu'on imaginait pendant
cette campagne présidentielle y découvre
ça alors maintenant seulement là pour le
coup je pense que ils ont ils ont raté
là ils ont raté un an de toute politique
en france il ya pour être capable de
faire c'est d'avoir fait ce qu'a fait le
président de la république actuel
c'est-à-dire démissionné se présenter
faire croire à françois hollande qui ne
lui qu'il ne ferait pas tout en le
préparant été très serré il faut avoir
il faut avoir une volonté de fer il faut
président qu'on la connaît tous les
traits autoritaires il est autoritaire
d'une tradition qui est une tradition
française et de la technocratie
française telle qu'elle est issu
notamment est incarnée par l'inspection
des finances dont il est issu et qui
pensent que l'état justifie l'exercice
de l'état effectivement justifier toutes
les duretés et pour le coup et c'est
ceux qui l'entourent lui ressemble ni
sonnerie là il a construit autour de lui
si on suit effectivement l'enquète de du
figaro magazine
on avait fait aussi du même genre ce qui
est impressionnant c'est à quel point il
ya une cohérence et une de la structure
élyséenne du groupe qui est extrêmement
fermé et qui reproduit l'attitude
autoritaire j'ai à dire alexis colère et
aussi peut-être plus autoritaire que son
que son patron lui même le le il y en a
qui en a fait l'expérience malheureuse
c'est le chef d'état major des armées
est ce que ça révèle aussi c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de maquereaux nice mandeure de
maquereau en fait c'est que macro en
fait et le visage donné à la
technocratie une vision pragmatique de
la politique mais qui n'est pas
idéologique qui dit pas d'idéologie
d'ipad militants donc pas de partie et
en fait il ne peut pas exister partie
macro nice puisque le maquereau nice et
la technocratie avec un visage et
d'ailleurs il
mais à croire que cette phrase dans un
discours récemment il a dit nous n'avons
qu'une seule obsession l'action nous
n'avons qu'un seul horizon maintenant
devant ça qu'est ce que voulait dire
c'est c'est une formule absolument
extrêmement technocratique et froide n'y
a pas personne ne peut être contre
l'action personne ne peut être content
maintenant et il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas d'idéologie derrière donc pas de
militants et pas de figure ils peuvent
émerger
et je pense que c'est révélateur sans
cesser de lui poser un petit problème
quand les élections vont approcher parce
que pour présidera bien présenter des
listes aux européennes en 2019 et
surtout qui est très content pour amener
encore plus compliqué pour un parti que
le maire patrick martin matte combien ci
avait pas de structure avant ces
élections municipales parce que là non
seulement il faut trouver des gens à
présenter dans chaque rue dans chaque
commune
mais en plus il faut des gens pour
distribuer les tracts et faire les faire
lesquels d'escalier comme on dit hélas
si les gens ne croient pas dans la
structure dans les dents les candidats
ils n'y vont pas vers les militants
n'iront pas fait les cages d'escalier
pour un leader qui leur sera imposée
d'en haut
juste parce qu'ils seront discipline
mais ça ne se fait pas pour la politique
c'est fini ça benjamin grand jeu nos
amis de l'institut ad'hoc sa ont sondé
les français cette semaine sur sur tous
ces sujets qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent
d'abord le fait que ce soit le précieux
la république qu'il nomme le patron du
parti est-ce que ça les choque alors on
a posé cette semaine une question assez
assez entière qui est de dire est-ce que
c'est choquant cette méthode est donc on
peut dire que plus de la moitié des
français jugent effectivement que les
modalités d'élection de christophe
castaner et on le voit d'ailleurs à
l'écran sont choquantes alors après
suivant évidemment les origines
politiques c'est plus ou moins marqué
les sympathisants du front national se
disent à 63% de choquer suivi de traits
de très près à 62% par les sympathisants
de gauche et ce qui est intéressant
c'est de regarder ceux de la république
en marche puisque on se souvient de la
fronde des sens et bien c'est quand même
17 % des sympathisants de la république
en marche qui aujourd'hui se trouve
choqué alors après ce qui est quand on
est allé plus loin on a creusé l'impact
en terme d'image sur le parti évidemment
sur christophe castaner alors il faut
savoir que christophe castaner si on
prend les réseaux sociaux est un
personnage qui est très appréciée on en
parle beaucoup c'est presque le sixième
personnage dont on parle le plus dans le
gouvernement et l'a finalement il
ressort de cette comment dire de ces
déclarations et puis de 7 cette échéance
avec une image un petit peu un petit peu
troublé parce que finalement le fait qu'
il puisse cumuler cette double casquette
ça énerve et s'abîment son intégrité
c'était évidemment ils étaient ils et
elles étaient reconnus reconnu comme tel
et avec une véritable sincérité et puis
finalement les modalités de sa
nomination sans vote aujourd'hui
elle appelle un certain nombre de de
critiques parfois d'ailleurs on dit est
ce que c'était c'est un parti comme les
autres et d'ailleurs c'était une des
questions que l'on a posé aussi cette
semaine et qui a abouti au fait que
trois quarts des français jugent la
république on marche un parti pas plus
démocratique que les autres alors je
vous donne en vrac les réactions des
internautes
jeanine reynerie qui nous dit la
république en marche est un parti
moderne plein de projets pour nos jeunes
lola but est moins enthousiaste je
dirais plutôt une secte et valérie roux
habits ajoute la secte et son gourou
alexandre trouve qu'en marche est un
parti du très vieux monde puisqu'il
incarne l idéologie d'extrême centre qui
a existé du consulat à la restauration
en france avec son kit féru d'histoire
et qui ajoute arrêter de dire qu'il ya
eu de l'enthousiasmé pour macron il n'y
a jamais eu d'enthousiasmé regarder les
scores du premier tour
macron 24 le pen 21 fillon 20 mélenchon
19 et demi car mais ça fait c'est pas
très nouveau que ce soit le président de
la république yves airault le patron du
parti
oui en fait nicolas sarkozy c'est la
même chose c'est xavier bertrand qui
était patron du début c'était patrick
devedjian qui faute de ministères ce qui
lorgnait sur le ministère de la justice
en 2007 et il s'est fait dépasser par
rachida dati et en sorte de lot de
consolation nicolas sarkozy lui a donné
le parti et il n'en voulait pas ça
l'intéresse pas et d'ailleurs il n'était
absolument pas fait pour ça patrick
devedjan c'est un intellectuel c'est
quelqu'un qui qui veut agir il n'était
pas du tout dans dans tout le travail
qu'il faut faire dans le parti qui est
un travail très ingrat donc à la fin
effectivement il a été remplacé par
xavier bertrand et françois hollande a
fait pareil l'un d'une certaine manière
il a au début garder harlem désir en se
disant ça ne posera pas de problème
et puis cotisants rendu compte car un
même désir non seulement ne faisait pas
bon mais n'existait pas du tout et que
ça posait un problème au parti bon ben
il a tout fait pour l'exfiltrer alors là
pour le coup il l'a mieux gouvernement
et l'ami jean christophe cambadélis donc
au fond on voit bien que le nouveau
monde ressemble furieusement à l'ancien
monde skis très amusant par rapport à ce
que disent les internautes et au
fonctionnement dans marche c'est que
quand on voit le fonctionnement nos
journalistes ont dit
au direct dirigeants de remarques non
mais ça ne pouvait pas faire ça le vote
à main levée ça n'existe que dans les
assemblées générales de l'unef ou ou au
parti communiste
voilà c'est ça quand on veut dire hors
is et les indécis qu'on veut on fait un
vote à bulletin secret première réaction
c'est pas du tout nous on est un parti
moderne au contraire de ce monde pense
la même chose ça nous dérange pas ça
sauf qu'à la fin
méfiant il se range à l'avis quand même
de ce ce qu'ont dit les observateurs et
donc demain il va y avoir un vote à
bulletin secret autre exemple mais avec
un seul candidat non là sur le bureau
exécutif pour le blu-ray + il ya
plusieurs disent par exemple pareil pour
lui il ya plusieurs listes pour le
bureau exécutif
4 ils sont tous d'accord quand même sur
le l'ensemble à la fin c'est qu'à cette
amère qui sera élu et vous avez quatre
listes mais les avaient pas confronté à
pas besoin de confronter deux façons ils
sont là comme ça bon et puis finalement
il organisait un débat vers comme ils le
font au dernier moment le problème
physique font un débat jeudi soir
diffusé sur internet sur leurs réseaux
très peu de gens qui l'ont regardé ce
que vous trouvez que alexandre sur un
sur lèze sociaux et est de mauvaise foi
quand il dit je trouve que le mode de
désignation du chef dans marche
ressemble beaucoup à celui du fn
c'est peut-être un petit peu exagéré
parce que la dernière les d'un des
candidats contre aironi aguanish
contrôler cette nomination lui alors qui
est vrai c'est que il y avait eu ni
dynastique et que
le poids du non le pen on a tous dit
compter énormément et donc elle avait il
y avait restait peu de danger mais il y
avait il ya une vraie contestation et
puis d'un projet un peu d un projet
différent puisque alors pour le coût du
projet était différent et donc là il ya
une confrontation de ligne au moment de
la désignation de marine le pen à la
présidence du front national
je trouve que il ya quelque chose qu'il
faut aux quels il faudrait un peu faire
attention c'est que d'une certaine
manière c'est pas encore un parti la
république en marche même façon que les
familles c'est oui c'est d'abord afin
oui d'une certaine manière c'est vrai
que ça se fait autour de la personne de
macron et que à partir du moment où
c'est très difficile d'organiser un
débat de ligne dans des structures aussi
jeunes aussi lâché aussi aussi dans le
cas on n'arrive pas à avoir à comprendre
comment se structure a déconné des
courants et donc on comprend que il ya
la tentation d'agir par le haut mais
celle un peu la même chose à la france a
soumises
parce que en fait jean luc mélenchon par
leur âge et de tout à l'heure lui il a
gelé le débat sur la ligne nous avons un
programme pas question de revenir dessus
il a dit le problème c'est le projet
présidentiel on a élaboré ce sens pas
question de revenir dessus alors qu'il y
avait des militants qui pourrait re
visiter certaines choses et la marche
vers l'élaboration de ce truc de la
structuration de la france a soumis
c'est un peu les mêmes hésitations parce
que là aussi il s'agit d'un concubin
d'un conglomérat à ses divers qu'on a du
mal structuré c'est pas comme le parti
socialiste où certains partis qui on
s'entend de derrière eux savent comment
on combat ensemble et à quel moment on
se retrouve à quel moment on peut
séparer à quel moment on peut faire des
compromis et ça fait voilà c'est la
différence le vin jean luc mélenchon
parlons-en
il ya deux que deux de nos confrères qui
ont lancé des enquêtes journalistiques
sur lui qui du coup lui envoyer des
questions
il s'agit de l'express et de capital et
jean luc mélenchon avec toute assez
original il a choisi de répondre aux
questions par avance sur son blog
de façon assez offensive je sais que le
canon à merde va encore tonné contre moi
cette fois ci d'ici quelques jours
capital et l'express veulent tirer leur
salle de commande alors on a vu le
papier de l'express
en fait ça revient sur des avantages
dont ils auraient pu profiter alors
qu'il n'était plus conseiller général de
l'essonne notamment une voiture
tout ça n'est pas forcément très nouveau
mais là la virulence de la réaction de
mélenchon laisse peut-être à penser que
quand on est de gauche et qu'on est
supposé défendre le peuple on aurait un
peu moins le droit de profiter du
système vous c'est votre avis gêné
basque et si on quand on a écrit un
livre qui s'appelle de la vertu où on
prône la nécessité de la vertu en
politique on peut on ne peut rien se
permettre et d'ailleurs il le dit
lui-même mélenchon il il est impossible
que j'ai commis quelques actes
délictueux ou immoral que ce soit en
attendant immorale car il n'a commis
aucun acte immoral mais donc c'est vrai
qu'il a une responsabilité
mélenchon en se posant en figures de
robespierre en matière et est
incorruptible
ça ne fait pas plus values un grand
forcément grosses sommes maintenant ils
n'étaient pas corrompus
donc je pense que de ce point de vue là
mélenchon en effet sans sur ses épaules
et responsabilités il sait qu'il ne peut
rien se permettre après je pense qu'il a
il est en train de glisser gains dans
une paranoïa par rapport aux
journalistes qui est de plus en plus
virulente son billet de blog et m
truffé de faim de voilà deux mots
extrêmement durs à l'égard des
journalistes d'ailleurs il se vante
d'avoir des taux taupin soumise à
l'intérieur des rédactions en lisant
j'ai j'ai heureusement dans chaque
rédaction il ya des insoumis qui
m'informe sur les enquêtes en cours mais
il ya une espèce de paranoïa qui
s'installe
enfin chez les dames la france soumise
et jean luc mélenchon vous avez des
journalistes et son n'est qu'un énième
épisode mais sur les enquêtes qui sont
sortis franchement ce qu'on me reproche
mais c'est vraiment des broutilles mais
nathan elle en fait trop
je voudrais pas être le juriste qui
défend jean luc mélenchon il avait
d'ailleurs ça n'est surtout pas de
journalistes pour ça non il n'en fait
pas trop si on se réfère à ce qu'il
pense du rôle des médias dans la
politique il avait fait une interview il
ya quelques années à média un
trimestriel qu'elle a expliqué qu' une
falaise et servir il fallait faire les
rails au régime fallait faire du judo
avec les journalistes
et c'est exactement ce qu'il a fait mais
lorenzo l'express je sais pas ce que
commencer parce que ce qu'il ya dans
capital on s'abstiendra de dire quoi que
ce soit en tout cas pour l'express il
les a devancé donc il a ruiné notre
enquête il les a un petit peu ridiculisé
parce qu'en fait ça fait bête de sortir
un papier dans lequel en fait les
réponses sont sortis déjà avant mais
aussi les nouvelles des collègues se
retrouvent en situation un peu
impossible mais c'est quelque chose qui
l'a théorisée avec ses amis qui étaient
avec de la pierre
il avait théorisé s'enlisant il faut
faire deux il faut faire des des médias
les représentants du système de montrer
que ce sont nos ennemis et avec cette
bataille là nous serons populaire chez
les électeurs je fume c'est çà et là il
est en train de reprendre il le reprend
avec que la violence qu'il avait il ya
quelques années qui avaient légèrement
baissé au moment des élections mais il
reprend quelque chose qui est une
manière de faire tout le monde se
souvient de cette altercation avec un
jeune journaliste stagiaire et un
terrien et qu'elle disait petite tête tu
es toi c'était extrêmement violents
vis-à-vis en plus d'un jeune confrère
qui était encore en écologie si je me
souviens bien donc il avait avec un
mépris terrible ok voilà il était
capable de ça donc il est revenu à ça et
je pense que il faut une certaine
manière c'est un sacré client pour les
journalistes oui je m'accroche parce que
le journaliste bashing fonctionne bien
je suis pas si le journaliste bashing
fonctionne bien en tout cas on a regardé
cette dualité c'est à dire est ce qu on
peut être de gauche ou d'extrême gauche
et en même temps riche et voir comment
les français perçoivent finalement cessé
ces deux notions
et finalement ce qui surprend voire
choque le plus c'est pas tant les deux
notions l'une à côté de l'autre
c'est plutôt la manière dont
l'enrichissement père
elle s'opère c'est à dire que pierre
bergé ne choque personne
voilà et pourtant il est à la fois voilà
il est à la fois il était à la fois avec
harry avec un gros patrimoine et en même
temps très clairement de gauche
en revanche le petit enrichissement
personnel
la gratte ce qui finalement passe pour
être une forme de combines avec tout ce
qu'on peut ce qu'on peut trouver des
petites affaires des doutes etc et c'est
vrai que si on creuse un peu raquel
garrido est l'élément là elle est un peu
pointé du doigt aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux
ça ce sont des choses et des
comportements même si on est dans le
domaine de la moralité et la plup la
plupart du temps c'est ça surtout les
compartiments qui les comportements qui
choque et peut-être les gens se rend pas
compte de ce qu'elle a été par exemple
la tribune je pense que le patrimoine
d'un pierre bergé ou d'autres
personnalités de ce type là pour les
gens c'est incompréhensible
la richesse de l'homme d'à côté le jean
que mischa fait une distinction entre
gauche et socialisme la gauche c'est le
parti du mouvement libertaire et c'est
pierre bergé de son point de vue là est
un homme de gauche libertaire prône
l'émancipation individuelle avant tout
donc on ne l'est pas eu déni qui n'est
pas de gauche mais c'est pas un
socialiste c'est pas un anti capitaliste
alors de ce point de vue là être ce
qu'on peut être socialiste et
anticapitaliste est très riche
je pense qu'à un moment difficile parce
que dans leur déclaration de patrimoine
dans les déclarations patrimoine des
différents candidats à la présidentielle
le plus riche c'était jean luc mélenchon
avec jeux de mémoire un million un
million 13 ans trente mille euros de de
patrimoine wick a réussi ce que vous
croyez que les électeurs voudront un
mélenchon de de dav de ces révélations
ou est-ce qu'ils sa dépense
si dans les révélations on apprend que
ce que je lis il a un peu gratter sur
des choses pas très légal ou pas très
moral de ses proches qui ont été
recrutés dans des administrations dont
il était proche
ça rappelle un peu la sphère fillon ça a
cramé fillon oui ça craint pas mêlant
chant ou c'est pas la même chose
il faut voir est ce que c'est la même
chose ou pas est-ce qu'ils ont un
travail effectif et ce qu'ils peuvent le
le démontrer la difficulté de françois
villon c'était démontrer que son épouse
avait travaillé et on attend toujours la
réponse de la justice sur ce sur ce
domaine là dans ce domaine là moi ce qui
me frappe surtout c'est c'est la dérive
dans laquelle et jean luc mélenchon par
rapport aux journalistes et aux médias
vous l'avez très bien décrit
effectivement il ya cette espèce de deux
confrontations qui est d'ailleurs la
plupart du temps sur jouer moi je les ai
eu plusieurs fois en débat et faut dire
quand même aux téléspectateurs que dans
les coulisses avant et après c'est
quelqu'un de charmant ni adorable mais
deux normales avec qui on peut avoir
discussion en revanche quand vous êtes
la caméra tourne et que là il est dans
la confrontation
donc il ya vraiment quelque part un jeu
de rôle après le deuxième aspect c'est
c'est le côté je crée ma chaîne de
télévision youtube dans laquelle je
n'invite que des gens alors il ya
quelques gens qui vont se confronter
mais globalement c'est les gens qui
pensent que moi et je crée un nouveau
média avec des journalistes qui seront
sur ma ligne
on est vraiment dans un domaine là où au
fond on veut rester dans son monde etc y
a rien de plus sympathique fictivement
des xsara monde avec des gens qui
pensent que comme ça mais la question n
attend finalement c'est ce que tout ça
est bien démocratique dans son esprit
vous n'avez pas de vouloir cogner les
journalistes la volonté y est d'écouter
d'abord je excusez moi de le dire ici
mais il est vrai que les médias les
grands médias et sont dans la main d'une
dizaine de très grands de très grands
groupes est faux de très bonne fortune
donc effectivement on peut se poser la
question de ce fait ils usent de
l'utilité quand même de médias
concurrents qui viendraient kititien de
reinette moi je
j'appelle ça de mes voeux de marianne
c'est un peu son but donc j'ai pas déjà
coûterait donc trouve normal que y
effectivement des voix discordantes et
que on peut accuser la place dans le
débat démocratique
le
on sait bien que d'une certaine manière
les électeurs le pensent aussi
subrepticement en tout cas puisque ça se
lit dans les votes
il ya un moyen preuve de penser
meanstream est donc un problème de
l'expression de la pensée en dehors du
mesrine maintenant moi je vais pas de
rush
on verra ce que donne arias deux choses
différentes la télé la télé que créer
mélenchon graal affrété les mêlant chant
mais payet certaine manière
moi je me souviens qu'ils avaient jadis
appelé la nation c'était le journal de
l'ue dr lala trigo la lettre de la
nation justement l'un souvient et il y
avait un jour il détaille aussi l'italie
ce qui s'appelait l'unité donc il est
légitime il était une époque où avoir
des journaux deux parties c'était
quelque chose de légitime sans compter
que les journaux enfin pour la presse la
presse une presse d'opinion nenê des
données aux réseaux de résistance soit à
la libération mais 144 par le général de
gaulle donc nous avons une tradition
comme ça voilà on va le gagner
oui l'humani par exemple une unité
organe central du parti communiste
français voilà donc il y avait ça le les
bleus l'autre tentative de quillan être
ce qu'ils foutent un peu plus différent
qui est un média normalement indépendant
du parti de jean luc mélenchon même s'il
y aura beaucoup d'amis donc on verra
comment il consiste à effectuer environ
c'est qu'au moins les autrement dit
comme si nous étions pas mal et jean luc
mélenchon pour le coup et avant gardiste
là dessus c'est à dire qu'il est
vraiment dans la dans la conquête de
l'hégémonie culturelle dans le combat
ira mes chiens ce qu il expliqué c'est à
dire que lui ne compte pas de faire la
politique mais il veut investir
également les médias le champ culturel
et je trouve que bien souvent la droite
devrait en inspirer
il ya pas vous trouvez pas qu'il parte
d'intimidation là dedans qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas sereine dans une dans une
démocratie non peut être
non je vais être vidangées jonathan je
pense que non alors disons les choses
les choses sont en train de changer pour
les journalistes ça c'est vrai mais
changent aussi
si on prend par exemple le latitude de
des manuels mâcon à la présidence public
a aussi un changement je veux dire les
journalistes politiques étaient habitués
à voir des gens trichent je ne savais
pas que politique était habitué à voir
leur entrée dans les allées du pouvoir
emmanuel macron mais rien pour faire un
truc bidon mais c'est important de
préciser que cette voie là ils bloquer
les portes pour aller dans soir c'était
que je sois là il est d'une certaine
manière
emmanuel macron est pas dans une
situation très fondamentalement
différente de celle de jean-luc
mélenchon
les méfiants vis-à-vis des il est très
méfiant vis-à-vis des médias et il
n'accepte que ce qu'ils contrôlent c'est
même effectivement nous avons aussi ses
toiles sur le prendre de secours
ailleurs ce que veut dire si on prend
globalement ça ce phénomène là les deux
ensemble c'est intéressant parce qu'il
faut à ce moment là enfin pour aller au
bout de ce que vous dites il faut dire à
noter secteur rappeler ce qui s'est
passé il ya pas longtemps avec un
journaliste de france 5 qui a voulu
interroger le chef de l'état qui était à
l'extérieur dans une dans une rue pour
avoir des certains de l'interaction il
est le service d'or des policiers en
civil et services comme l'ont écarté je
me souviens enfin je n'ose pas imaginer
que si savez ça s'était passé sous
nicolas sarkozy
la bronca non mais c'est important là on
a l'impression que ça se passe tous nos
confrères et consoeurs bowie c'est pas
très grave
non c'est très très grave là pour le
coup jean luc mélenchon n'y est pour
rien non mais c'est parce que comme dit
eugénie vers ses mails macron a la
possibilité de le faire avec des
services d'ordre
jean luc marchand il est pas loin de
l'opération et jean luc mélenchon et les
moyens de faire taire beaucoup de gens
n'aillent est négative je voulais
revenir sur la sur la chaîne youtube de
jean luc mélenchon parce que
habituellement il et il a montré qu'il
était assez bon sur sa communication
digitale mais là ils s'attaquent quand
même à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que d'abord sa demande
des moyens enfin vous savez ce que c'est
vous médias que dany mais finalement une
chaîne vidéo vous voyez la nature de
médias une nature de l'engagement
et là il va falloir qu'il change un peu
de catégorie donc on va voir
il faudra juger sur pièce de la réalité
de cette chaîne
là c'est l'expert en communication qui
parle d'une évidence n'est pas gagné
seulement vous je vous propose de nous
intéresser aux prières de rue peut être
vous souvenez vous que depuis plusieurs
mois des musulmans prient le vendredi en
face de l'hôtel de ville de clichy la
garenne qui est une ville delà de la
banlieue parisienne
parce que leur lieu de culte avait été
fermée la préfecture autorisé s'est pris
hier le maire lui ne l'entendait pas de
cette oreille il ya eu des
manifestations un peu forte d'opposition
entre les deux camps vendredi dernier et
finalement le préfet des hauts-de-seine
a décidé de d'interdire ces prières à
clichy la garenne
est ce que c'est une bonne décision ou
bien est-ce que s'ils n'ont pas de
culture il est normal qu'ils puissent
prier dans la rue eugénie bastié déjà
faut remettre les choses dans leur
contexte c'est à dire que le maire a
fait fermer un lieu de culte enfin la
passe à faire un lieu culte mais loué la
mairie prenne des précédentes qui des
socialistes par clientélisme louer un
local à une association musulmane qui
s'en servait pour lieux de culte le
maire heller a été élu il a dit je vais
construire un nouveau lieu de culte qui
fait de mille mètres carrés un qui est
un peu excentré il a dit tous les to les
associations musulmanes se sont rendus
dans ce lieu de culte sauf cette
association là qui a refusé en
prétextant que le lieu était trop loin
insalubre et pas assez grand voilà un
cadeau à t il donc le
ils ont fait ces manifestations pour
obtenir un autre de culte à l'intérieur
du centre-ville donc faut remettre les
choses dans un contexte c'est pas comme
s'ils étaient complètement à la rue il y
avait un il y avait un lieu de culte
prévu d'ailleurs c'est après la
médiation qui était trouvée ils vont se
rendre finalement dans non ce lieu de
culte il faut mettre voilà les choses
dans leur contexte
je crois que la décision du préfet était
la bonne enfin d'interdire maintenance
et maire de roeulx était la bonne parce
que si ça n'a pour moi ça n'a rien à
voir que la laïcité puisque l'espace
public on a droit de faire des prières
de rue dans l'espace public il faut
qu'elles ont été déclarés c'est le cas
de deux processions par exemple
catholique etc
c'est ce qui est dérangeant c'est
l'espèce de mise en scène victimaire
qu'utilise certaines associations
militantes musulmane pour faire croire
qu'elles sont victimes d'oppression en
france et d'ailleurs y avait marwan
mohammed le président du ccf qui est
assez controversé collectif contre
l'islamophobie en france qui était
présent au début des manifestations et
qui comme ça à alimenter en disant nous
avons besoin d'un centre dans un lieu de
prière à l'intérieur trop vite pour
montrer que nous existons nous sommes là
à l'intérieur au centre de la ville et
je crois que ça devient dangereux quand
c'est manipuler par des parrains islam
politique et militant voilà
hervé nathan je vais aller dans le même
sens ce qui moi je trouve que la
décision du préfet a été un peu tardif
mais s'il aurait pu agir plus tôt pour
éviter que ça devienne un scandale
national
ça faisait huit mois donc on peut se
demander ce qu'il faut voilà pourquoi
l'état permet ce genre de choses moi je
suis assez opposés non pas aux prières
je suis assez opposés aux prières
utilisé comme un élément de
manifestations je pense que là pour le
coup est un dévoiement la pratique delà
de ce que permettait aux laïcs c'était à
la procession qui est une
de rendre grâce à dieu mais une fois par
an une fois la romance et ses rites et
ses donc série spéciale c'est une non
mais c'est pas simplement c'est une
tradition
il arrive que la communauté juste au
moment du nouvel an se rendre dans
certains lieux sont les mieux public
parce que notamment près d'après de
l'eau parce que ça fait partie des rites
mais c'est parce que ça fait partie du
rite alors la même façon professé de la
procession c'est une tradition mais cela
fait partie du rite on sera en
procession parce que il y à un rite de
la procession dans l'église catholique
c'est pas juste une tradition donc hélas
il pourrait y avoir une nécessité
d'avoir une preuve une procession pour
les musulmans je connais pas assez là je
ne vais pas m'avancer plus que ça mais
là il s'agit d'une utilisation de de la
prière dans un but tout ce qu'elle plus
profanes qui est d'obtenir un avantage
un terrain un local pour une association
alors qu'en fait il ya aussi aussi un
autre aspect c'est qu'à des bisbilles
entre comme une autre entre courants
et origines au sein de la communauté
musulmane et veulent pas prier ensemble
je dirais aussi ça qu'ils doivent gérer
les préfets les moeurs comme une
difficulté donc l'utilisation de la
prière comme acte de manifestations me
semble mois déborder de ce que de
l'utilisation normale de l'espace public
pour la fst quand on manifeste c'est
pour vous dire quelque chose alors on
revendique quelque chose nous on vient
pas chercher dieu pour ça en plus car ma
vie c'est explosif politiquement ce
genre d'image parce que il ya une partie
des français on l'a vu dans le passé
qu'ils sont extrêmement hostile à ce
genre de manifestation bien sûr et cette
affaire et a pris de l'ampleur à partir
du moment où les élus de la ville de
clichés les élus régionaux d'île de
france ont décidé de porter ce débat là
sur le terrain politique en organisant
une contre-manifestation l'aise avec
leur lot reichardt voile alors on l'a vu
ici même vendredi des remords et ça a
donné d'ailleurs lieu à un certain
nombre de commentaires un petit peu
surprenant où on lisait que c'était les
élus qui perturbait une prière de rue
d'ailleurs l'association musulmane qui
organisait ces prières a porté plainte
contre la moelle assez pour faire contre
la mairie alors que voilà pour le coup
j'ai dû rester a bien résumé la
situation en l'occurrence c'est vrai que
leur local a été fermé mais qu'il ya eu
une autre proposition donc utiliser la
prière de rue comme chantage c'est
vraiment jouer avec le feu dans une
situation aujourd'hui qui est
politiquement très tendues pour
alimenter le débat je vous propose qu'on
écoute maintenant
abdallah zekri il est membre du bureau
du centre du conseil français du culte
musulman pardon et président d'un
observatoire contre l'islamophobie en
tout cas dénommé tél il était ce matin
sur ses news écoutez le problème
actuellement en france il faut doubler
le nombre de lieux de culte doublé
doublé l'année a déjà 2500 ils sont à
peu près dans les 5000 pour pouvoir cinq
mille mosquées en suisse à mille lieux
de culte que je dis pas des grandes
mosquées cathédrales jeudi des salles de
prières de quartier afin de mettre fin à
cette prière dans les rues qui te
quitter je dis merci c'est une demande
qui vous semble légitime ça fait penser
à le coût à l'achat de pays qui
s'étaient bien al azhar au moment de 2
tous les débats sur la laïcité au début
du 20e siècle est dit on peut pas pour
chasser les gens qui s'assemblent pour
dire leurs prières on peut pas empêcher
ces gens-là prier enfin on ne peut pas
leur interdire de prier donc à
l'importation moment là on est bien
obligé leurs enfin ils ont le droit
d'avoir des lieux de culte je pense est
plutôt qu'ils se soient dans des caves
ou finalement oui soient pas contrôlés
ou là où la police ne puisse pas se
rendre par exemple pour observer les
prêches etc je préfère que ce soit dans
des lieux publics
quand on puisse voilà après la question
qui se pose c'est comment financer ces
lieux de culte comment où les mettre ce
que c'est aux mairies de de vendre débat
afin de brider bail en trafiquant joue
un peu avec la loi etc
il ya beaucoup de voilà deux questions
qui se pose est ce qu'on doit autoriser
justement ces mosquées cathédrales qui
sont très visibles avec les minarets etc
où est-ce qu'on doit privilégier des
lieux de culte plutôt discret ce qui moi
et mon avis mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il va falloir qu'on sont des
lieux de culte mais c'est intéressant ça
parce que justement on a besoin de
salles de prière pas forcément de
mosquées cathédrales hervé nathan ça
vous paraît une bonne distinction c'est
à dire des lieux de culte oui mais pas
forcément ostentatoire comme aurait dit
jacques chirac
moi je partis moment où les où il ya des
règlements d'urbanisme
il ya des règles qui sont fixés sur la
hauteur des constructions sur leur
intégration dans le site cesser les
mêmes pour toutes si je vois pas
pourquoi on ferait des règles ou des
interdits spécifique parce que il y
aurait un truc qui s'appelle une tour
qu'en fait on a vu qu'on appelle
nouveaux minarets mais qui de ce fait
une tour qui dépasse et ça fera un
problème moi je pense que en soit ça ne
fait pas de problème sauf si ça dénature
totalement un paysage historique etc
on imaginait milan presse a pas
forcément ça devant notre dame de paris
à la place de la préfecture de police
mais je connais ne connais pas bien
l'urbanisme de la garenne colombes par
exemple je suis pas sûr mais il ça fait
du bruit on peut considérer que voilà
c'est comme les cloches à une
réglementation sur les cloches on ne
gagne pas quand on veut non plus donc on
peut aussi régler tout ça là là la
france est un pays administrés on a
beaucoup de règlements et en fait ils
suffire on s'aperçoit qu'il suffit
surtout les appliquer de manière le
préfère je reviens dessus par exemple
préfet aurait pu intervenir la prière de
rue plutôt sa révision
et peut-être la solution serait venu
aussi plus vite voilà il ya construit
sur le jeu sur la construction des
mosquées ou des lieux de culte d'abord
on a construit beaucoup d'air le faut
faire attention à part prendre comme ça
les l'idée que ce serait interdit
partout il ya eu quelques difficultés
dans certaines municipalités mais en
fait l'installation de l'udc delà des
communautés dans des lieux de culte
s'est répandue serre que ce qui n'était
pas le cas on n'est pas il ya vingt ans
en arrière il ya beaucoup de chose par
contre il ya un vrai problème pour le
financement
on attend toujours que les musulmans je
n'ose pas dire à la communauté parce que
moi je pense que quand on connaît un
petit peu c'est un fait ils sont quand
même assez divers donc que les musulmans
s'organisent pour le financement rompent
avec les financements effectivement à
l'extérieur du pays
rompe avec le fait de faire venir des
imams salariés soit pas la turquie soit
par le maroc
voilà il ya tout ce travail là qui est à
faire et qu'il faut pas simplement
s'arrêter au fait que le chiffre il
faudrait doubler le nombre de le nombre
de lieux de culte moi oui ça vous n'en
faut certainement plus en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que les principes
républicains font que les gens droit de
effectivement de prier dans des
conditions décentes c'était un principal
tangible de notre république
fallait il faut le faire appliquer mais
il n'ya pas que ça quand même si le
groupe préfet a mis huit mois avant
l'intérêt ses prières de rue c'est
peut-être le reflet d'une très grande
prudence du pouvoir en général sur sur
ces sujets oui tout à fait là on avait
exactement l'exemple alors on sait qu'il
ya un maquereau on va prononcer un
discours au début décembre sur la
laïcité
donc c'est il va être très attendu et au
fond il valait mieux que ce soit apaisée
du de ce côté là parce que sinon tout
son discours aurait pu être pollué par
la polémique de clichy je vous propose
qu'on passe un sujet qui n'a absolument
rien à voir avec le précédent et qui
part d'une vidéo absolument incroyable
que merouane mais hadji qui nous a
rejoint du figaro.fr va nous présenter
tout de suite mais roanne c'est à vous à
la naissance d'un robot de l'entreprise
boston dynamics qui a dévoilé une vidéo
pour nous présenter voilà il est à
l'image vidéo qui a été vue près de 3
millions de fois aujourd'hui sur youtube
bon ce bébé il est déjà grand isle
fait un mètre cinquante et soixante
quinze kilos beau bébé et atlas c'est le
nom du robocop que vous voyez il réalise
des prouesses qui n'avait jamais été
possible de faire jusqu'à maintenant
pour un robot humanoïde
il réussit à faire un salto arrière sans
s'écraser au sol
c'est la première fois bon par contre je
voudrais rétablir une vérité je sais pas
si on va le voir au moment où je vais le
dire mais dans cette même vidéo ce qui
n'est pas forcément dit sur twitter pour
les personnes qui le commente
on voit atlas s'écraser les pieds en
l'air parce qu'on peut le voir
finalement ça marche pas à tous les
coups alors évidemment encore vous et
quand vous êtes derrière la caméra vous
ne gardez que ce qui fonctionne et ce
qui l'est pas par faire acte e mans
rennes attend vous le trouvez comment
est techniquement c est ce que il prend
du plaisir à faire
il a peur de se faire un claquage à la
réception quand on voit certaines de
yahoo
voilà il ya des choses est ce que le
robot a peur ou est ce qu il a du
plaisir alors une question d amiens je
le trouve mon flippant que le robot
précédent qui s'appelait spock mini une
sorte de chien à quatre pattes
d'ailleurs lui aussi à l'effet quelques
prouesses techniques dont l'une des
premières non pardon excusez moi c'est
pas des prouesses et des soucis
techniques
l'une des premières réactions du
prototype le chercher un peu du mal à
lâcher sa canette
je sais pas si on peut le voir à l'image
il va arriver cette vidéo ne fonctionne
pas parfait alors c'est vers la fin de
la vidéo
bon il avait du mal à lâcher sa canette
pour la donne à son maître et il avait
finit même par perdre l'équilibré à la
fin de la vidéo sans qu'on sache trop
pourquoi
sur twitter puis bon c'est sur twitter
que nous aussi on nous fait ça on tombe
sur twitter rafik smati qui est
entrepreneur dans le numérique se pose
la question de savoir si demain nos
robots seront nos assistants uno
exterminateur quant à nos chercheurs
français ils se sont émerveillés devant
cette prouesse technologique de la
classe celle que je vous ai montré tout
au début mais pour en savoir plus je
vous invite à lire l'article de marché
qui a requis sur lefigaro.fr aujourd'hui
qui s'intitule premier salto arrière
d'un robot un exploit incroyable pour
les spécialistes
merci beaucoup gdba cc vous trouvez ça
fascinant et inquiétant ces images
du tout impressionnant pas vraiment non
mais je suivais l'affection que cet été
je suis allé voir le lac le lac des
cygnes de tchaïkovski à
saint-pétersbourg et j'ai vu les petites
ballerines danse et je me suis dit le
jour où des robots arrivons à danser
comme ça avec une telle grâce je serai
impressionné mais ce qui est aimé mieux
cette seconde réflexion c'est qu'en fait
les êtres humains résisteront robot par
le corps davantage que par le cerveau
parce que ce qu'on voit en fait
actuellement c'est que ça c'est des
gadgets le vrai péril c'est
l'intelligence artificielle et comment
les robots en fait remplace notre
intelligence et non pas nos gestes
physiques et là en fait tous les les
robots humanoïdes sont bien plus en
retard que l'intelligence artificielle
est beaucoup moins dangereux est
beaucoup moins impressionnant ça c'est
vraiment des gadgets fait pour
l'impressionner épater la galerie mais
mais en fait c'est par le sel c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'imiter
finalement le corps humain que
l'intelligence humaine notamment
d'enfants dans le calcul etc
et c est là le vrai robot kiki intrusif
et qui dans notre vie quotidienne c'est
le téléphone portable c'est les moteurs
de recherche tous qu'il automatisation
qui c'est ça la vraie la véritable
menace tout ça c'est du gadget comme je
veux qu est un sportif accompli n'est
pas été non plus impressionner par ce
rôle là on a vu la vidéo effectivement
il se casser la figure qui le rend
vraiment beaucoup plus humain parce que
pour voir des vidéos aussi de surfer sur
les pistes ou sur les vagues où on voit
ces montages c'est formidable un présent
qui réussissent tout mais évidemment ils
ont coupé au montage tous les moments où
ils se sont cassés les figures comme
étant directement sans filet ce qui est
intéressant aussi par rapport à
l'intelligence artificielle ce que juni
bastié il ya un petit incident qui est
arrivé cette semaine qui est assez
amusant c'est que vous savez il ya un
site internet qui classe les restaurants
en fonction du nombre d'avis favorables
tripadvisor pour ne pas le nommer
c'est vous qui le nommer et du coup il
ya un petit restaurant de quartier qui
cette semaine a dans le show qui dans le
10e arrondissement a reçu des coups de
téléphone notamment du crayon disant que
d
et des personnes voulaient aller dîner
dans ce restaurant oui mais on est quand
même tu as 30 quartier c'est pas a
priori pas là votre clientèle si si si
si ils ont vu sur 13 heures vous avez la
meilleure note pourquoi parce que c'est
l'algorithme qui classe en numéro 1
le restaurant en fonction du nombre de
davie et si tous les ennemis sont
favorables il est numéro un on voyait là
quand même que le robot a encore un peu
de temps avant de remplacer l'humain
parce que effectivement depuis le
restaurant a chuté dans le classement
puisque certain nombre d'avis moins
favorable c'est le même un riche
américain qui est allée qui a dit je
voudrais du champagne
oui et alors on lui a dit bah voilà ça
coûte combien 90 euros et la peinture
il doit pas être très bon après là c'est
pas assez cher mais revenons à nos
robots benjamin oui là c'est vraiment le
cas de pas d'intelligence artificielle
sans faire de jeu de mots [ __ ] bêtise
d'artificiel et je pense que l'on va en
voir quand même pas mal
moi je voulais revenir sur leurs pas sur
le lac des cygnes mais sur la dernière
série de deux matchs bio qui s'appelle
ouest world est en fait elle pose de le
débat en fait de l'usaj amoral des
nouvelles technologies parce que cette
série l'1 c'est en fait un parc
d'attraction avec des humanoïdes
donc il ressemble vraiment à ce que l'on
est et finalement pour l'ensemble de
ceux qui visitent le parc d'attractions
et bien on peut tout faire tout faire
avec ces humanoïdes on les prend comme
des esclaves
on peut tuer on peut etc et donc ça pose
sa pose et sa anticipe un certain nombre
de questions de la société
finalement exploiter les robots pour
gagner plus c'est une voie là où on
imagine très bien ce que
voilà le en tout cas les utilités mais
en même temps ça pose la question de la
menace est donc cette série là elle est
intéressante dans son l'état soit dans
sa manière dont elle pose le débat
vraiment vous sentez menacés
enfin pas vous personnellement je pense
que mes génies que le vrai le problème
armée nation peut-être c'est un terme
fort mais le problème sur lequel nous
sommes confrontés dans les animés date
maintenant c'est l'intelligence
artificielle va prendre un diabète
algorithmes vont dominer la vie
quotidienne des gens chez nous avons eu
un problème que tout le monde a vu
devant nous on a parlé s'appelle apb
vous savez le la médiation post bas vous
savez il ya eu un tout - à 10 h
eh bien les gens tous m'ont dit ça a
buggé sap a buggé du tout en fait c'est
un algorithme qui n'ont classe les
bacheliers en fonction de leur gueule
allez vous pouvez aller là là là ou là
mais et il a vraiment fonctionner de la
manière qu'on avait prévu qui
fonctionnerait et donc il a été jusqu'au
bout et la france entière tout cas
l'état l'éducation nationale a accepté
que de l'intelligence artificielle
décide de l'avenir de nos jeunes du site
de l'art de l'orientation nos jeunes
d'une certaine manière donc nous sommes
déjà rentrer là dedans et c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose pour le futur
donc on a vu donc on a vu la limite la
limite la limite a été simple limite
c'est que le gouvernement en fin d'année
d'administration un v semble fait
semblant d'ignorer qui aurait quarante
mille candidats de plus à l'entrée à
l'université cette année que l'année
précédente et que eh ben ça on est allé
au bout du hendrick à la fin le robot
apb a dit ben tanfous tire au sort parce
que il n'ya plus d'autres moyens et ça
c'est revenu de 0-2 devenu un problème
humain est un poème politique pour
revenir mais sur ce sujet je pense que
le grand remplacement que la robotique
ça va pas être l'humanoïde du tout donc
ça va être l'automatisation
j'avais fait un interview d'un d'un
spécialiste américain du numérique qui
s'appelle nicholas carr qui avait fait
un livre qui s'appelle qui s'appelait
internet rend-il bête est là qui fait un
deuxième livre sur l'automatisation de
la société est dit que le problème c'est
que l'automatisation nous promet une
libération en fait des tâches aliénante
en disant voilà on va vous libérer mais
en fait nous libère de ce qui nous rend
libres c'est-à-dire précisément toute
cette culture
enfin tout le tous les défis de
l'existence en fait en nous facilitant
la vie on ne fait plus sentir le prix de
la vie la liberté et il compare enfin en
anglais le titre cédait de glace key de
la cage de verre etc le sait s'est
inspiré du cockpit des avions qui
aujourd'hui entièrement automatisé en
fait les pilotes ne servent plus à rien
et les factions et sont là pour vérifier
les machines pour surveiller les robots
mais finalement une pilote plus ils
n'ont plus de lien avec leur appareil
est en fait sous ios ou liberté avec
c'est un terrible ennuis et il met en
garde sur le fait que voilà sept ses
tomates automatisation des sociétés nous
nous allier ni notre notre notre travail
et qu'il faudrait faire
enfin racks et la technologie davantage
sur l'humain que sur la technologie
elle-même parce que là il ya un espèce
d'autos sont heureusement de la
technologie sur elle même oui pourrait
dans le même sens c'est effectivement
les robots conversationnel les fameux
chat bottes et aujourd'hui envahissent
le plus notre quotidien et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est cette chatte
bottes
si on se remémore finalement 1950 et
alan turing alan turing avait avait posé
un test consiste à dire avec un certain
nombre de 2 pendant cinq minutes si le
dialogue avec une machine permet de
tromper 30% de cinq juges
eh bien on considère que il a une une
apparence
humaine en tout cas doté d'une
intelligence qui se rapproche de l'homme
eh bien il se trouve que le test de
turing
il a été il a été réussi en 1900 en 2014
le en juin 2014
et depuis cette depuis cette date là les
tchats bottes et les agents
conversationnels ne font que s'améliorer
devenir de plus en plus intelligents et
la vraie question que ça pose c'est si
on a des agents qui sont intelligents et
sur lequel on ne peut pas avoir
forcément de déterminisme sur ce qui ce
qu'il sorte c'est comment l'homme peut
effectivement les contrôler parce que
c'est ce que vous par exemple parmi vos
clients il ya des gens qui vous demande
mettez en marche des robots qui vont
dire du bien de notre société où nos
produits sur internet
en fait pour l'instant c'est surtout
dans l'optimisation c'est à dire que
quand on pose des questions sur twitter
quand on pose des questions sur facebook
quand on pose des questions sur les
forums des marques est bien plus tôt que
ce soit des comment dire des gens
derrière qui répondent
et bien c'est dans un premier temps un
robot qui va faire un premier tri qui va
faire un premier filtrage qui va se
poser la question si cette demande là
elle concerne le service client ou si
elles concernent plutôt une réclamation
leurs éventuelles et qui avait comme
unité non on est on est pas tellement on
n'est pas tellement là dedans c'est
surtout sur pour l'instant c'est surtout
l'optimisation de là où il ya une forme
de come on dire de main d'oeuvre et qui
nécessite de répondre 24 heures sur 24
et 7 jours sur 7 c'est le service après
vente
ces voix là c'est tous les centres de
contacts clients c'est là pour l'instant
que il ya le plus de demandes mais il ya
beaucoup de demandes
c'est à dire que c'est pas on n'est pas
dans quelque chose de très ponctuel mais
aussi le
un secteur en me suit la défense où pour
le coup la sd or beaucoup plus mécanique
mais toujours pas humanoïdes mais parmi
les robots tueurs et le musc patron de
tesla avait alors alerté il ya quelques
années en demandant à l'onu d'interdire
les robots tueurs
parce qu'ils ont faim ils prédisaient
que ça pouvait devenir une catastrophe
puisque des robots fait qu'ils ne sont
pas qu'ils sont programmés pour tuer et
finalement aucune confiance pourrait
aller beaucoup plus loin que les humains
dans l'horreur six tentes et d'ailleurs
ont pu être plus cruel comme humain
lui-même mais et donc ils mettaient en
garde contre ça et notamment les drones
aussi les drones absolument quai qui
existe déjà et bien sûr ces
réjouissantes perspectives et j'espère
de mon temps que gâcher votre week-end
par l'internaute
cette émission de pointu est terminé
merci beaucoup à tous les cinq et on se
retrouve lundi prochain mais à suivre la
chronique d'eric zemmour qui va nous
dire le sujet d'actualité qui l'a arrêté
cette semaine hervé nathan va regarder
ça avec art et rennes il va nous aider
bonsoir
[Musique]